з там вузлових україна вранці allow всього
20 символів у ціну 1 бал краще не що
рік таким чином з приляг узиста 68
вкрай кольору українська держава під силу
130 місяців у team ціна 2 носити позитиви
ще не що рик із сусідом і в україни з
таким ішхан ібн і ми поки що знайомі
став і іран камерон напав нікарагуа і
парагвай
то позитив списку щодо сили давання
фінляндія таш адже я reven корупції там
найменший autumnal на слова на та
коропова нижчих краєм почету
disto ласпі зовнішні кореї то сомалі так
ще пофарбують і свої позиції українці
вдалося за дико створи new
антикорупційному органі впаяли руку в
ліжка фку руки або news uz
пильного суду взяття кревності до
повідаєте transparency international
україна сама форма діана на uri adobe
організації то журналісти руслі давайте
став ручну силу зрад у краї не в тому
високо по саду актив до серця
притягувати девід паве дальності обидва
готівкою карають за їхнє зло чини
та йди сюди по бачимо заданому та нижчому
досвічуванні від розпарилася
international україна на ідиші на
корупцію у краї не скажете підприємство
хабара вимагати перу важливо з перу бітних
та підкової служби ми відзначте
агентство земельних ресурсів пожежні
служби томі летимо на та чистий
підприємстві прямо з дахаба риф при о
формула не документі на землю офіс чен
ір вухо помста а також пити годину видачі до
дверний документ за річками на лося і
аграфія корупції в Україні
я вчора не шиною хіба хрупова нам у
органам у влади поважалося іудейське те
тпр p6 антирейтинг упа сили
ivano-frankivsk а то за ризиком області
найму та шкуру кованим у бізнесмена
поважає чиновники фу хмельницький
черневицька то тернопільська областях
світлові рейтинг прийняття куру бті
transparency international складу і ширше
що стягнути україну за допомогу та досвіду
Ваня
міжнародних фінансових то
правозахисник експертів